so back in the dark days of the web
doing anything even remotely fun with a
auto video we tell the real-time
communication that was the that was the
domain of plugins and you know we don't
really like plug in zee this is no
longer true you know we have a fantastic
mix of low and high level API is that we
can sort of manipulate this stuff send
data between machines and you know
manipulate audio and video it's great
stuff to show us how to get the most out
of those api's I'll introduce our next
speakers some do taan and yon Linden
everyone thank you thank you very much
Jake I've never been called that before
yeah i am sam gutelle I'm a developer
advocate for crime based in London and
I'm yarn Linden I'm a product manager on
the crow media team with the special
focus on audio and everyone knows chris
wilson who is going to be performing for
us a bit later so i can get my clicker
to work there's going to be a quite a
lot of links in these slides which might
work better you know online them on the
screen here so if you want to follow
along these slides are up at simpler
info / media so I think we've seen two
big changes on the web and you know
these have happened really suddenly the
first is the stuff that Linus was
talking about the the rise of this
multi-device web you know we've got more
mobile phones than like toothbrushes or
pencils and so on here's this
commoditization of of computing that we
not a scale we haven't seen since like
the pc boom of the 80s and 90s but the
thing is that it's not just kind of the
same thing with more computers and the
change of devices is actually you know
changing what we're doing on the web and
in particular like Jake woods referring
to you know we're seeing like though you
know the rise of audio and video and
real-time communication on the web and
you know this is in a sense I think a
lot of it is to do with the fact
we're using these devices now which are
you know naturally oriented to to
consuming media media and communicating
no phones and tablets and so on this is
actually having a knock-on effect
elsewhere and you know I mean a lot of
us when we watch television now we do
other stuff with mobile devices you know
we access other media while we're
watching television and in a lot of
countries in fact TV viewing is down
online viewing is up i just read
actually in the Economist about china
that you know in beijing like only
thirty percent of people now access like
user television and that's down from
like seventy percent of households you
know like three years ago like I mean
popular online shows in China you know
they get audiences of like 250 million
and so the predictions are that within a
few years like something like maybe
ninety percent of the bits that cross
the internet will actually be video this
translates to something like a million
minutes of video a second just
incredible so I mean it's not that we're
all going to build you know the next
YouTube or whatever but we're coming to
expect this kind of seamless audio/video
real-time communication in our apps and
we're expecting that on all our devices
so what have we got well we have these
media api's for the open web and you
know we have these interoperable
standardized technologies that you know
working across a huge range of devices
so in the next kind of 25 minutes we're
going to just try and touch on you know
some of the things we can do with those
api's on web perhaps you know the best
place to start I think any more feedback
is WebRTC this is perhaps the most
ambitious overused word but you know
disrupted really disruptive projects on
the web this is real-time communication
built into the browser open source
you know plug-in free free for end-users
free for developers and this has been
like I don't know a missing piece of the
web platforms and there's kind of
crucial for building web apps on on
devices which are oriented to
communication so maybe the best way to
show this in action is let's have a chat
we have well i'm going to use opera
actually on the on the desktop here okay
so dress android tablets i think i can
see someone else has already joined us
there we've got firefox running over
there yeah on the on the nexus and then
chrome for android on the nexus 7 and
you can see that that's working pretty
world and this is like a full mesh setup
you know everyone connected to everybody
so it's not actually particularly you
know particularly efficient hello Brian
so I mean this is great you know we're
seeing great stuff coming through with
WebRTC we've got really great adoption
firefox chrome and now opera on desktop
and on androids bindings for java
objective-c and yet pretty recently cute
cutie framework started using chromium
which gives us access to loads of stuff
including web RTC so we have well over
now a billion endpoints and a lot more
predicted for the for the near future so
the kind of I guess the obvious use case
for WebRTC is you know video chat like
we were just showing but they've been
some really innovative apps coming
through just back in August kind of
helped out by a company called v-line
sky did live interview in South London
there where I live and they did that all
with WebRTC you know the old days to do
stuff like this you needed all this kid
all these people is tracks you know all
this stuff and they did it with this
really simple setup using like a camera
like I've got here and one of these 100
buck Yeti mics and nothing this is
amazing this is like the democratization
you know
of broadcast I love this stuff so um you
know in the old days real-time
communication involved something like
this this highly simplified diagram but
you know you were required to go through
some kind of centralized service and
essentially that box in the middle was
acting like a relay service which is
just inherently inefficient perhaps the
most radical thing about WebRTC is that
it's its architecture is inherently
peer-to-peer so in other words you know
wherever you're calling from so to speak
whether you're on Wi-Fi or on a cell
fixed whatever the idea is that you can
communicate these streaming data
directly between peers and this is of
course far more you know far more
efficient and better for performance so
what do we need for real-time
communication well obviously we now need
to be able to get audio and video you
know from our camera and our mic and
then we need to be able to make a
connection between the two peers you
know the caller and the colleague and
that needs to be able to cope with the
real world of naxx and firewalls and so
on once we've made that connection we
need to be able then have really high
performance streaming that works you
know works in this modern world of you
know multiple devices so you know audio
without jittering and video that's
smooth and so on and so on and so on and
I guess the the other part of WebRTC has
also always been this idea that we could
communicate arbitrary data as well so
not just audio and video but all types
of data binary data text and so on and
we're seeing some you know really
interesting use cases for that coming
through so for this we have three api's
media stream people may be no better as
getusermedia has anyone here built an
app using getusermedia that's great
that's like the most i've seen if that's
fantastic and then of course we have our
tcp connection and RTC data channel
shall talk about a bit so you know on
one level this is kind of a simple
constant
so you get some some media and then you
plumb that into our tcp connection to
get it to the other side once you get at
the other side you you got you've got
your media streaming then you can do
something like plug that into a video
elements of course it's not that simple
RT seek peerconnection the bit in the
middle so to speak needs to cope with
the real world like I say of gnats and
firewalls and so on and also to be able
to do clever stuff to make sure that
video and audio work really really well
across a range of devices in a range of
contexts echo Karen Alicia and all these
things yeah record for a good experience
yeah there's a you know a stack of stuff
that that goes on in you know incredible
detail in the in the design they're
obviously peerconnection the whole of
WebRTC is also designs you know with
security and minds so at every stage
everything is encrypted you know within
within the code and when you're
communicating between peers which is you
know kind of crucial to this project so
if you want to have a look at web RTC
check this out this is kind of the
absolute basics we also have a kind of
full-fat video chat app which is
maintained by google which kind of does
everything and has really verbose
logging so it's a you know a good place
to work out what's going on think about
RTC data channel like I say this is the
API for other kinds of data arbitrary
data yeah imagine you're playing a game
and highly simplified but you know you
want to exchange player positions for
example and do that with with low
latency and kind of effectively you know
trying for real time where we have you
know RTC data channel for that and this
has exactly I know who is ringing
someone so this has exactly the same
api's WebSocket but you know what we're
aiming for his is really low latency
firstly because the idea is that you
communicating directly between peers and
you know using the like sctp protocol
means we have a lot of the advantages of
UDP so what
we can do is optionally specify that we
don't need the connection to be reliable
in other words you think if you're
exchanging player positions it doesn't
matter if you lose some packets along
the way what you really want is high
performance whereas safer file-sharing
you know you can't lose any bits that's
not going to work so you might take a
slight hit on performance to make sure
that that the transport is reliable so
again if you want to check this out it's
a good place to start just wanted to
show you a really nice app I've seen
using this I don't have people have seen
share fest but what this gives us the
ability to share files using RTC data
channel without having to go through an
intermediary service so what I've done
is I've selected a file there chef s
gives me a URL and then I can do
something like post that URL to someone
and then they can open that that file at
the other end so when they come to open
that file a peer connection will be
established between the two browsers so
to speak and then data transfer the file
will happen directly between the two
without like a site going by an
intermediary server so kind of
interesting stuff going on there perhaps
a more radical project have people seen
like peer CDN this this blows me away
this is this idea of a peer-to-peer
content distribution using RTC data
channels so the way it works is that you
put a link to peer cdns JavaScript at
the top of your web page and then the
way it works is that it will try then to
get assets on the page from local peers
rather than defaulting to downloading
them from the server so yeah it's a kind
of prototype but you know it's this kind
of vision for a really different way of
doing things on the web so I kind of
skipped over getusermedia I just wanted
to sort of go into that little bit more
detail getusermedia is pretty
straightforward you can see here I mean
you call get user who gives a meter on
the
navigator object and you pass it a
constraints object this is actually
really powerful this is defining what
kind of media we want in this example
all I'm saying is give me video you know
just give me the default video and then
the success callback is is passed a
stream which then you can do what you
want with let's see that in action in
fact so yeah I'm going to page this
calling getusermedia notice that I have
to explicitly allow access to my camera
there and then bang we're getting video
from the I've got a USB camera plugged
in there you can see so hello everyone
what's nice about this though is when
you see these I don't know you know
these api is coming up against each
other so in this example we're getting
video from the camera and we turn around
this way and you can actually see
something what's happening is we're
getting frame grabs from the camera
plumbing those into a canvas element and
then analyzing that canvas element pixel
by pixel to give us ascii art which is
it's just nice when these you know these
these a POS can interact like this
thinking about working with constraints
we can also use constraints to select
the resolution of our camera so wow
that's slow if we if we go to this web
page there we go in fact let's look at
the source for this on github if that'll
open you'll see if you can see how this
bump up the size a little bit we've got
three different constraints objects
these like each represents a kind of low
medium and high res so to speak so when
we click the button here we're getting
640 x 360 right up to HD here which is
our sorry I've still got the other one
open here so let me just close that and
then
to pull that through again so basically
we've got the ability to to choose
resolutions there we get you can see I'm
getting the full HD from hello wave to
the camera yeah this is kind of crucial
of course also when we're thinking about
getting you know getting media from a
mobile device and and making sure that
you know we're not overdoing it in terms
of bandwidth um we can also use
constraints to select camera sources so
let's do that now I'm going to go for
this on on the device here let's in fact
let's show it on mobile device i think i
can actually if we look at over here i
would share to you okay sure so
basically we can get the ID for the
different devices attached to the
machine and then we can select different
cameras depending which we want and as
you can imagine this is kind of bizarre
weird yeah we this is crucial again for
you know devices that like phones and
slates where we obviously want to be
able to do selfie mode or kind of crowd
made so there we go yeah okay that's
right just remember for a selfie selfie
is good and again this is all done with
constraints same with with screen
capture we can do the do the same thing
so i'll just go out of full screen mode
so we've specified in the constraints
that we actually want to get video from
screen capture which you know it's
slightly ridiculous because we're
getting a screencast of a screencast but
anyway you can you can imagine there are
lots of lots of kind of good use cases
for that people ask about recording we
have an API for this coming through
being specified and implemented media
stream recording for recording audio and
video there's also the the media stream
cab image capture API which is kind of a
taking photos API you know you can do
that with
use a media in canvas but this gives us
access well is proposed to give access
to stuff like camera auto focus and zoom
and so on so I think that'll be great
again you know really good for mobile
devices so there's a lot about video
yeah this one again could tell us a
little bit about the world of audio yeah
what's video with that audio that's
pretty much nothing isn't it so let's
focus on audio a little bit so we have a
great thing that's been around for quite
a while the audio tag well supported
very easy to use and it takes care of
everything loads decodes buffers and
plays out your your audio and even
include say a player's you don't have to
do anything more than that line and you
can play an audio file that's great but
there are applications where that is
just not enough for example precise
timing is super important in gaming and
being able to have many different sounds
at the same time in the music creation
etc so we came up with a Web Audio API
and the Web Audio API is really just a
it's a pro audio environment in the
browser and it involves a lot of stuff
so let's let's start with the just the
look at what you can do for as I said
you can timing but you can also do cool
things like create audio so here is just
a semester
and all this through audio is created by
Web Audio and with all the controls you
can switch things on with perfect timing
at any time you want and some of the
things you go
run away
I'm not going to stay up all right so
Web Audio can do that so we just saw an
example of creating audio we can do
timing we can also analyze all your data
super nice applications are for example
visualizers and things and even if you
still want that all that long file you
want to download with the audio tag then
you can just plumb that into Web Audio
and you get the ability to add
visualizes effects it's that on top of
that so audio tagging and the can come
as a way of loading audio into Web Audio
so I'm not going to go into all the
details about Web Audio it's just such a
powerful tool and what's really nice all
these things are implemented in in
native code in the browser so you don't
have to do this in in javascript in
JavaScript you have a nice node based
pipeline where you just plug in things
and easily put it together but it's
really Pro Audio so for example a good
example is that we can have input to
output in five milliseconds and I'll
give an example of all that matters in a
second the support for for Web Audio is
also really great it's really a pleasure
to note that Firefox just two weeks ago
announced or released a web audio on
both desktop and Android this means that
we have web audio on Chrome Safari
Firefox on desktop all desktop platforms
on Android and iOS so an oppressor sorry
yeah that's that's so new that it's not
even in my mind so it's not even on our
slides it's your fault okay so one thing
that's really really exciting and we
started with this that we have all these
media API said that they work together
and we can do really really cool things
together one example is how you hook up
getusermedia that Sam talked about and
showed video examples but you can
obviously use that to hook up your
microphone and get an audio stream and
do something with it and a great thing
you can do is you can plug it in as a
source in web audio so you get a
microphone input that's the source in
Web Audio then you can apply anything
you want in web audio for example one
great example would be you plug in your
guitar you plug it in here and the audio
that comes into Web Audio you can apply
filters and effects and then you play it
out 5 milliseconds later so basically
you have an effects box in your browser
but let's not only talk about this let's
show something and listen to something
here many of you have probably seen this
before Chris here he built a vocoder
which is a great instrument for i/o last
year and since then here I'm sorry I
should since then he has on this
continent a new nation conceived energy
and so anyway composition so since then
he has added live input as we just
talked about get used media but also now
this works on mobile hope I camera see
if I get the camera hello chrome dev
summit helps
log in the Nexus 5 I did also want to
say the synthesizer also works quite
well even on iOS there are some couple
of issues i'm still working through with
firefox but it really shows that these
things work across mobile and desktop
it's not just on the desktop well we are
not in your life like it ok next thing
when you have the audio in through
getusermedia to web audio then you want
to plug it in to peer connection and
then you can talk to someone on the
other side through WebRTC call and apply
the effects next thing we want to do
there is apply these effects on the
output as well that's in the works so
you can for example do specialization
the output from a web RTC call ok Chris
another great thing that we need for
audio is being able to not only use the
keyboard and stuff you actually be able
to connect midi devices like listen or
let's look at notice before i was
playing this keyboard that's connected
through the web MIDI API but we also
have a couple other apps that we've oh
how would you plug the audio back in May
we had something else coming there we go
ok
alright good they were gonna dance I
just kind of looking rich music
that was completely the key or leave
this probably better they don't the real
key here though is that you really need
for a lot of audio applications you need
this very hands-on controller experience
and I can do things particularly you
okay we are quickly running out of time
here so let's skip to some other
important things for the web and media
on the web one thing that we really
think is super important for this to
really work for the open web is open and
free video codecs so we had developed BP
8 and that's been out for for several
years that really address what you need
today but we didn't stop there now we
also have vp9 which is the next
generation that saves more bits at a bit
at a really good qualities you can look
here at the bars in the middle so we
compared h.264 and vp9 you can see the
bar is the bit rate how much we save all
the time for the same quality this was
from google i/o so really a great job
from our engineers to do this and this
is open and free and can be can you just
be anyone for no cost the tools other
important things for a full media
experience is being able to for example
do adaptive streaming your bandwidth is
not always the same you need to be able
to to handle changes in your bandwidth
and the media source extensions one of
the things they do is allow for that we
also have encrypted media extensions
that make it possible to handle content
protection and then leave for you for
things like yeah so we get so good at
one minute this yeah a few minutes left
if any we got a little bit extra so yeah
we've got a great support for audio and
video range of platforms also thinking
about like captions and subtitles and
accessibility and we got great support
for this as well just looking I don't if
people have seen the track element this
is kind of a simple simple way of adding
subtitles or captions to to your
applications chug chug chug okay their
web is always changing yeah and you can
see there that you know we've got track
subtitles rendered over the video and
then I'm listening out for the cue
change events and then you know plugging
that stuff in a div there so just a
really simple way to to make your video
more accessible and to add that stuff
the way you do it is that you add a
track element to as a child of the video
element and then you point that to a
file it looks like like this which is
just essentially some information about
timing and then the the text of in this
case the subtitles there's also some
some information about the way the
subtitle it's kind of hints about how
they might be rendered there this little
link down the bottom here actually I
think this is amazing now implemented in
chrome is the ability to do what's
called in band webvtt this gives us the
ability to bundle a track file with
video file in order to you know be able
to distribute 11 file that contains the
video and the okay the you know the
whole thing in one package in one file
so we run out of time here but I just
like to to go like just a one more demo
that I think that you know really for me
sums up how far we've come with audio
and video on the web and here you'll get
the real doubts yeah this slightly weird
video shows like what we got here is two
videos encoded with alpha transparency
information and you know these are just
video elements so that is weird so we
have the ability to do you know like CSS
filters these are just elements we can
double click on these and I've got a
little CSS animation double-click the
background you know we have a video
playing in the background so you know
actually these are like basic sort of
green screen video
but you know actually the rendering is
is really stunning so yeah I'm just that
I don't know really pleased to see that
stuff so yeah please we you know we
really really look forward to seeing
what whatever I makes of these api's
because i think they are a great feat of
engineering and incredibly powerful
across the only got to touch on a few
things here but yeah there's much more
so yeah okay thank you very much